[Music]
all right we're back
yeah i didn't hit i didn't hit the
computer i just kind of went
i just kind of went out we have no idea
why this
is uh the connection's good we're
connected with a lan
cable so it doesn't have anything to do
with what's really strange because like
you're i kept looking
because he's got his uh you know tablet
over there and i kept looking at the
tablet and it was still going
but on my computer it was like
everything just for something to do with
this laptop and it's only been
it only started about two weeks ago
didn't it two or three weeks ago it
started doing it we've never had any
problem before yeah we've been streaming
with this all right
and you haven't been using that for
anything other than this no i don't use
this for anything else
because i have two other computers i
think it might need some kind of
software update i mean that should
happen automatically
it does happen automatically i wonder
what it's doing i don't know maybe i can
maybe i can upgrade the ram maybe or
yeah i have to like look and see
into this kind of into this kind of
because this is kind of a cheap ass
yeah it was a cheap laptop we just
needed to use it to [ __ ] stream with
yeah because like i said i got my mac
back there i use that for graphic design
and i got this pc here that i use for
video editing
yeah this one i don't use it for
anything other than this
we should be able to upgrade it somehow
maybe there's a i think it could be a
program problem
who knows software i'm too dumb to
figure that [ __ ] out i don't really know
i don't know it could be one of any one
of a million things okay they're still
coming in there's 16 in there
yeah tammy we need his t-shirt
sammy said that we need a t-shirt that
reached 13 o'clock irregular
yeah i like that idea yeah she's like
that would come up with something neat
like that
uh it's almost time for us to start
shooting new shirt
shirt designs yeah we probably should i
just haven't covered but she's just got
her hands full she's [ __ ] working for
a couple of other people at the same
time and then we're getting uh
doing cookbooks we're doing the cookbook
still yeah we haven't even got all the
true
the next true crime book i have the
first two chapters of that written
but that's it but i got a whole bunch to
be a long [ __ ] i got a whole
bunch of screens
that i can set up i got two of them set
up and i think yeah we bought a bunch of
screens
five or six other blank ones uh so i can
come out with a
when she comes up with the designs i
could come up with some [ __ ] real real
quick
yeah i had some ideas and jenny had some
ideas uh you know
yeah we'll we'll come up with new ones
yeah i feel kind of bad i'll run it next
week i'll run it by you guys
yeah see which that actually would
probably be a good thing to do is just
show them the pictures
showing prince first yeah and then
everybody would be like which one should
we
make yeah you know yeah um all right so
where was i so i did number eight
already so i'm at number seven
yeah because i was waiting for you to
come back because i said number seven
you've actually seen this one and number
seven
is train to busan i love this movie
2016. i do as well
one of the best one of the better uh
zombie movies and yeah easily for
reasons
it's korean easily one of the best yeah
i mean korea like a lot of the
korean movies we've been seeing recently
have been like really really good
particularly horror movies part two to
this
was okay yeah peninsula was a little bit
of a letdown
yeah it was not a crystallized movie
like this one
it was kind of far-flung i think it
tried to open up the universe a little
too much
yeah because i think the great thing
about train to busan is that it's set on
a train and so there's only like a few
characters it was character-driven
yeah it wasn't about situations and and
bigger scope they tried
it's almost kind of like he was trying
to make the foundation for a series like
something walking dead maybe
yeah i did kind of get that impression
yeah so i thought but um i mean it's not
a bad movie
it's just not great the one that was the
better
was kind of like the train to boost on
the prequel
what there's a preacher there's a one
yeah that's called seoul station soul
station
that was good but that's what i was
talking about the other korean one about
the guy that was got trapped in his
apartment oh hashtag alive
hashtag alive if you like trying to
boost on you'd like to hash to tag alive
it's good yeah the zombies looked
actually kind of we we speculated that
it might have been set in the same
universe
yeah it had to been it was because the
zombies looked very much the same
and but korea's laws are going to be
different
yeah i mean like making a zombie that
looked like that would probably wouldn't
be a copyright violation in in korea
yeah like i don't think you could do
that here in the united states they'd be
like hey those are our zombies
you know they had there's like anyway
you know you know what i'm talking about
yeah
so uh because they do that even with
star trek you own a star trek license
you can only do a certain kind of star
trek you can't do
original series or anything like that
you know so korea i think is a little
more lenient than that but it
hashtag alive if you like training
boosts on see alive
sydney lane said we don't speak about
the ending of trying to busan the end of
train to busan
is so sad yeah this is like one
that's what i'm saying about how
character driven it was i mean it's
great like the [ __ ] zombie
action is great in it it's like there's
some good gore and [ __ ]
um but man when certain people like the
[ __ ] end of this
is this is maybe the only horror movie
like where the end of it like made me
tear up so
yeah it's like really really sad the end
is very sad
because you care that much like a really
lot about the characters you know no
pass not a bad ending it's it's a good
ending it's just sad
it's just really kind of sad it's really
sad yeah
all right number six
get out 2017. jordan peel
this was kind of like i had us on here
too but it ki but it got like uh
shifted off because of whatever and
honestly i think i loved
us but i think get out is probably a
better movie objectively
it's essentially it's kind of like
the stepford wise it gave me like a very
stepford wives
kind of vibe like in a good way you know
what's funny about us
what's that cause i think there's
something there was something missing to
the theatrical release that we watched
in the theater
i bet you there's a director's cut
that's longer that makes that movie
better there usually is because there
was some stuff that was
seemed to be missing that made the movie
kinda
slightly incoherent not totally
incoherent
but it was like there was some [ __ ] that
was missing yeah notice that
yeah maybe like i said i i really did
like that but we saw it twice right i
think we went yeah
we saw it twice it was great yeah but i
i really suspect there's about 30
minutes missing from that
maybe one of these days we'll buy it on
blu-ray and see we just got to look to
see if there's a director see if there's
a director's cut there yeah
i just suspect that there was some
missing from that yeah
yeah kind of like they kind of like with
old [ __ ] dr
sleet yeah which yeah who absolutely
made it
made a big difference yeah um but yeah
so
uh yeah get out was my number six my
number five was
it follows from 2014.
i forgot that one this one is basically
the premise of it is that it's kind of
like it's a sexually transmitted
kind of demon like something
will come after you you pass it from
person to person by having sex with them
but everyone's demon looks different it
just looks like a regular person but
they like just keep following you until
they kill you or until you pass it to
someone else
and but only you can see the person you
know what i'm saying
it's like it's a genius conceit for
because well like when i was watching
the movie i'm like [ __ ] man why didn't i
think of that
yeah it's so good because you don't know
who the monster is you could just be
like walking around and then somebody
starts like walking towards you that
just looks like
you know somebody but you're the only
person that can see them and then
they're just gonna come get you so you
have to like go [ __ ] somebody else and
like pass the curse on to them you know
what i mean
yeah so yes it was like a [ __ ] great
idea and it had just had some really
really great like
creepy [ __ ] scenes in it uh
number four i'm gonna go with uh starry
eyes also from 2014.
this had alex esso in it who played
wendy in dr sleep
um this was the first thing that i saw
her in
this is a very much um
hollywood selling your soul for fame
story um it's like a faustian
type thing because she wants to be a you
know a movie star
yeah and um you know the [ __ ] that she
will go through to do it like she goes
to this [ __ ]
uh audition with these super super
weirdo people and obviously you know
that they're like [ __ ] demons or
satanists or something like that and
they're gonna make her do the stuff
and it's just as the story goes on
if you're squeamish about like body
horror you might want to skip
this one because [ __ ] is pretty [ __ ]
gross like all the [ __ ] that she goes
through because essentially
they're like well you have to go through
like a bodily death so you can be like
reborn
as this you know satanic like now you're
like a movie star
so basically like all her [ __ ] teeth
start falling out or hair starts with
like a fingernails it's like super super
gross
and then there's there is a murder in
this too that
was really uncomfortable to watch like
somebody got killed like with a [ __ ]
what was it like a [ __ ] uh a dumbbell
or something and
like right right in the face it was just
like really like horrifying
but yes it was like a really really good
play um
what oh i thought you were gonna like
say something yeah number
three yep mandy yep one of my favorites
so i got that good i got the silk poster
of this movie framed in the bedroom yeah
[Laughter]
this great movie i mean
it's a movie about a dude
who got jumped by a damn cult of
weird-ass jesus freaks and killed his
woman
and then he got his hands on some killer
acid
and he's just on this intense acid trip
that and you go and you're on the s
trip with you you were also on the acid
trip you're fighting demon bikers and
[ __ ]
weird christian cult they weren't they
weren't christians they were just some
kind of weird jesus-y freaky
they're kind of like the source family
which is what we're going to be talking
about on the show on saturday
yeah i think it was supposed to be
taking place in the 80s wouldn't it
yeah yeah it was said in the 80s but
yeah it's like you could tell from like
the [ __ ] they were wearing [ __ ] that
they were wearing stuff like that
it's just um it's an exp it's not a
movie it's an experience yeah
he's tripping out he's having like
[ __ ] cartoon hallucinations that look
like something out of heavy metal
magazine
or some kind of frankfurzeta [ __ ]
drawings and [ __ ] it's just
bizarre it's got um
it's got the dude that played mac from
uh
predator in it what's his name bill duke
great what's it bill dukes yeah yeah and
he's just
this old dude living in this [ __ ]
trailer full of flies
he's preaching wisdom to him and giving
him weapons cages in it
just caging the [ __ ] out it's a
masterpiece
it's real i mean it's so so weird and
it's just so
so good yeah but i mean and if you
haven't seen like um
that dude's first movie which was beyond
the black rainbow
that shit's [ __ ] weird too i haven't
seen that one i've got to see that one
we watched it one night but maybe you
were maybe we were drunk and you don't
remember it
it's so it's super bizarre it's really
really bizarre
i don't know i kind of feel like mandy
is more bizarre in some ways but beyond
the black rainbow
is kind of like i had no [ __ ] clue
what was going on in that movie i really
did it's like it's cool and it's like
cool to watch it like it's a cool visual
experience but i'm just sitting there
going this is not making i don't
remember it
yeah it's crazy yeah um but yeah so
easily easily
yeah you guys in my top five yeah um all
right number two
i'm gonna go with the invitation from
night uh 2015. this it might still be on
netflix i saw it on netflix
maybe a year or two ago this is
basically about
a dude with his new girlfriend and he
hasn't seen his ex-wife
in like two years and they had a kid and
the kid died so they you know they broke
up over it or whatever
and her and her new husband invite they
have this dinner party so they invite
him and a bunch of their other friends
to their house this kind of like remote
house i think it's up in the hollywood
hills somewhere
and um to kind of like reconnect with
everybody
this movie is like i think it was
directed by karen
kasama who also did uh jennifer's body
this is one of the most
tense movies i think i was sitting like
literally on the edge of my seat the
whole entire time
because i didn't really know and i
really don't want to spoil like
what happens because i love like dinner
party horror because that's like a whole
like little
sub genre you you really don't know
what's happening and i like that they
that she plays with the ambiguity for
such a long time like the main character
you're not sure if because you have
reason to believe that he's like well
is something weird going on here or is
he just being paranoid
because some [ __ ] that happens it is him
being paranoid so they kind of like play
with your emotions like that
yeah and then it just it it's one of the
best
like most suspenseful horror movies i've
ever seen like i was just sitting there
like that like tense like through the
whole thing because i had no [ __ ]
idea what was gonna happen
and it was just really really really
well done and i feel like
not a lot of people have seen it or talk
about it or whatever
um i don't know like i said i saw it on
netflix but that was probably
i don't know a couple years ago so i
don't even know if it's on there anymore
but if it is and if you like that kind
of it's
it's a thriller i guess but it goes more
toward horror
toward the end like it gets you know
banana pants like at the end like all
the crazy [ __ ] that happens
all right and my number one will
probably come as a shock
to nobody number one hereditary yeah we
saw it in the theater we did
i love this movie i love this movie so
much that i don't know if i ever want to
watch it again because it stressed me
the [ __ ] out
i want to see it again i want to see i
want to see it again we saw it in the
theater with some friends with sean on
them they've been on the show before
and i was sitting there and i don't know
what it was but i was watching that
little girl when her head got smashed
off i [ __ ] laughed that was because i
didn't really expect it but i thought it
was kind of funny
and then remember when her head got hit
by the thing yeah she showed up and i
was just going god damn
and i thought that was a weird looking
little girl
yeah i think she was this might be her
first movie because i think she was more
like she's more like a stage actress or
a broadway actress
yeah i'm looking to go what the [ __ ] and
then i kind of
so lost touch with really like that
[ __ ] noise that she made like that
yeah yeah she made wow i have to see it
again and then i lost kind of touch with
reality and fell asleep
and when i woke up it was at the end
well you didn't even know what was going
on i didn't know what
was going on but i was laughing though
there uh they were they were
somebody was crawling around on the damn
ceiling on the wall
that was the trip then i fell back
asleep again and then i woke back up and
they had
the damn body and his [ __ ] display
and [ __ ]
laid out at the very end and i was like
man this movie was probably pretty cool
but i [ __ ] slept through it
yeah so i got to see it again i was
tired at the time
yeah i was tired at the time and i will
say i think tony collette got [ __ ]
robbed i think she should have got an
oscar nomination for this
she is amazing in this movie
and and i love just like in uh midsummer
i really really like there's so much
[ __ ] going on in the background of this
movie
that you don't you have to see it like a
couple times and like i said i
i i've watched it one time in the
theater and then i've watched like
videos about it and i'm always kind of
like man i really want to watch it again
but then i'm like man i really don't
want to watch it again because it really
really
[ __ ] me up and like stressed me out
it's one of the most
actually i think it might be the
scariest movie
i i've ever seen it just really really
bothered me
it's almost kind of like somebody i saw
a review of it and somebody called it
something like emotional terrorism it is
kind of like that it's just
it had this and i know it doesn't affect
everybody the same way but i've talked
to like some other people that have seen
it that you know
that reacted to it the same way that i
did it's just i don't know it just made
me really really
uncomfortable it made me feel really
really bad it scared the [ __ ] out of me
and it's i had nightmares i think for
like two weeks after i saw that [ __ ] and
i watch horror all day [ __ ] long
and that never happens so i was like
really really excited
because i was like man this is the first
movie in decades
that scared me as much as like the
shining scared me when i was a kid
yeah you know what i mean like oh i
don't want to go to the bathroom because
that [ __ ] naked lady is going to be
in there
you know what i mean it's it but i was
like little when i saw the shining or i
was kind of like you know maybe 11 or
something
but this movie gave me that feeling as
an adult i'd have to see it again man i
want to see it again we'll buy it
yeah and i mean just there's so much
[ __ ] going on in the background it's
just
so some good movies you kind of only
really only want to see once
yeah you know for a certain like uh
i saw a joke and i loved it somebody
sent me joker yeah we lost who it was
because he lost a damn piece of paper
probably probably hernandez he sent he
sent a lot of stuff
and when i got it i was like oh man this
is a great movie but then i said but i
don't know if i want to see it yet
it's one of those like because it's kind
of like it that movie is so well made
and it's kind of painful to watch yeah
in a certain way you know because he's
like
he's just a real uncomfortable character
and then the way it goes i gotta see it
again though it's been a while since
but that's what hereditary did for me
sorry i saw the one time and i was just
kind of like
i don't i want to watch it again so bad
but i really really don't
on the other hand because it's just it
just made me it freaked me out so
[ __ ] much
i don't know why it just hit that spot
and like i said i'm not the only person
but i know everybody doesn't react to it
the same way because some people said
it was scary because you know how
there's always like [ __ ] edgelords to
do that kind of [ __ ]
but yeah so um but i thought it was
carrie and i'm admitting that right now
and i said like i said i watch horror
movies all day long they don't scare me
i enjoy them
um sometimes they have like little bits
in them that i'm just like ooh that was
creepy or you know
but this movie legit gave me like bad
nightmares
like for a long time afterward like
after seeing it so it's like i'm not
really sure i want to
delve back into that because it was so
anxiety-inducing
so that is the uh the this was the list
the greatest
so we finally got through it it only
took [ __ ] five million hours i told
you it was going to take that long no it
didn't
i mean you're not two hours two and a
half hours
well no we've been on an hour and well
the first one was hour 44 minutes and
then how long
20 minutes so we've only been on 20
minutes and we weren't talking about the
list the whole time because we talked
about like some other [ __ ] like to start
with so it wasn't quite that
thanksgiving
thank you zach just says anything here
you can go ahead and read it if it says
anything hereditary made me cry about
four times and help me rediscover my
religious faith how many people can say
a horror maybe did that
see i can totally see that reaction i
mean
it's a [ __ ] brilliant it's a
brilliant piece of filmmaking
okay i mean seriously i want to i wish
like ari astro would make more [ __ ]
movies already he made midsummer as well
yeah but
both of those yeah maybe maybe we can
get both but like i said i'm really
going to have to psych myself off you
know what
i know that makes you sound like a [ __ ]
but i was just like any horror movie
i'll just watch it all day long i don't
even care if it's like gross and chill
like martyrs or whatever but the
blueberry collection is getting so big
we have to [ __ ] make a place to put
it
i mean we're gonna need this taken up
we're gonna need some bigger shelves
i could maybe i can move it in here
somewhere and make it part of it i don't
know man there's not a lot of room in
here but maybe we can find some space
for it i mean you can't really put
anything there because that's where the
door opens yeah
um so i can't really put anything back
there because it'll [ __ ] the door up
i don't know we'll figure something out
maybe transfer some of the stuff out of
there and turn that into blue rays or
something then put the i don't know
it's hard to say yeah maybe over here or
something i don't know
we'll figure it out yeah so we wanted to
talk about something else though right
have we
how long has this stream been going only
22 minutes okay so
yeah um notice that it starts [ __ ] up
around what is that about an hour and a
half hour and a half to about an hour
and a half two hours is the [ __ ] the
laptop starts [ __ ] up so i think it's
running out of some kind of memory
yeah maybe i don't know i mean it says
it's only at 36
capacity 32 capacity right now
so okay it's which is good but that
didn't seem to make any difference when
it was jamming out maybe not something
else
now can we please talk about that
ridiculous
nostradamus [ __ ] yeah so here's we just
watched this randomly we were on
to be or hulu or whatever yeah and um we
were just scrolling through like
document because tom's like i feel like
watching a documentary so we're like
scrolling through documentary [ __ ]
and you know there's a bunch of ufo crap
and
yeah and then he's like oh there's like
a nostradamus one i think it was called
the nostromo's effect
and it was just the history channel made
it and i think it came out in 2008 2009
2008 something like that it's pretty
it's so it's pretty old pretty old
but he's like that looks hilarious we
should like [ __ ] watch that and just
like scoop on it
it had like an antichrist theme where
they got a dude kind of looks like from
[ __ ]
omen three yeah that's totally who they
were
podium commanding [ __ ] legions of
evil you know in
a one world government and it's 2008
oh and it's got the dude voi the dude
that does all the voice overs for
[ __ ]
history channel the sounds important
like from ancient discoveries
i had forgotten because i thought that
like the history channel
making this kind of stupid crap i kind
of felt like that
was a more recent development but i was
like [ __ ] man it's like that was from
like 2008 2009. that was like a long
time ago
so they were making crap like way back
then history channel was
was very entertaining i was watching it
back then when i could
and it was it was most of it
was entertainment and it was stuff like
this but it was meant to really excite
you
now some of the stuff like ancient
discoveries you know what i mean that
was a good one you know it's all about
the antikythera device and
yeah greek fire and it's based in yeah
see that kind of shit's cool yeah that
was really cool and it's the same guy
that did the damn voiceover
and they uh they also talked about the
[ __ ] that the chinese had come up with a
lot in the
1400 steam-powered [ __ ] naval vessels
that were gigantic and [ __ ]
we need to know about that kind of stuff
i like that kind of stuff
ancient chinese secrets you know what i
mean that's
gonna look commercial basically what
yeah remember yeah
ancient chinese secrets what's that from
that was from like this it was calgary
gal god detergent
research [ __ ] chinese laundry
yeah yeah and they came up with some
crazy [ __ ]
and my dad one time he's like you know
remember this [ __ ] i i know it i know
exactly yes
oh my god that was discovery channel but
they're all owned by the same [ __ ]
yeah that's right yeah you could eat i'm
pretty sure now discovery channel
i i'm trying to do his voice
i used to not believe mermaids but i saw
a program
i believe there are mermaids out there
like mermaids yeah it goes back
thousands of years the greeks had
drawings of them and
they were talking with them and fighting
them and there's a lot of accounts and
and you know i was just going this is
[ __ ] because yeah
they had whole scientists talking about
it scientists yeah
what's the name of this program you know
he told me the [ __ ] program the
episode and everything i gave it to
jenny i said jenny man
this might be something we got to put on
the show cause i was talking to him on
the phone when he's done it yeah and i
said jenny man we gotta look into this
[ __ ]
jenny's already going oh come on it's
like mermaids aren't real yeah and so
she looked it up and what it was
it was a special and it was a
mockumentary
yeah and he [ __ ] he's from agenda and
he fell for it it was a mockumentary if
it wasn't
from she thought it was real that they
made that [ __ ] for shark week
or what is shark week or or yeah i think
i think they're weak right
yeah it was much monster week that's
right this is a couple years
i said
[Laughter]
but it was on it was on discovery
discovery got a lot of [ __ ] for that
actually did that yeah yeah
anyway he finally finally convinced him
that it wasn't real
and he says oh man i thought that was
real
i was all disappointed i wanted some
mermaids god damn it
history channel was doing some adjacent
adjacent [ __ ]
like that back in 2008 i thought i
thought a lot of it was great
and this is a good example of it but it
was great entertainment
it wasn't really great information it
was just great entertainment all right
you could take a little tiny little
little bitty thing
and if you put enough graphics and you
have a [ __ ] good enough voice
over you can spin any narrative you want
off of just like a couple of lines
of a quatrain pulled out of [ __ ] one
of nostradamus's books
and even a fake quatrain they'll put
that in there too yeah because one of
the
at least one of the ones on there um
almost 100
certain that that was a fake one that
came around because um you know since
the advent of the internet people have
been making up their own [ __ ]
nostradamus quatrains
like to fit in with whatever thing and
then
they kind of just get passed around and
they get
and people think that they're real
because what was the one that
actually mentioned america and i'm just
like that is not a real
nostradamus no that that's not a real
you guys just pulled that off a couple
guys going there they love my impression
of my dad
to tell the stories you want to hear his
real voice it's like that
yeah that's just that's what it sounds
like pretty much um
that's so funny yeah
yeah the one about america they're
reading
a lot of times what they'll do with the
nostradamus quatrain is that they've
been interpreted and reinterpreted over
and over again by successive
interpret interpreters and it probably
originally didn't say that it would
probably say like the new land
yeah so which could be anything that
could be anything
sure so then they come back and they'll
write america
yeah because that's who he was talking
about you know the fire came down in the
new city
that's new york in america anything in
the new land as
is america yeah which that was what
when did he live fourteen hundreds
fifteen hours something like that so
maybe they knew about
the new world i don't even know if they
were calling it america
no that's that time because they didn't
they named that after like america
yeah and i think that was like what a
century or two after
they found it yeah
but columbus bumped into it like on the
way to asia
trying to get so what is this doing here
actually he never did he never
he never hit the lake that north america
it was probably somewhere like haiti or
something
it was somewhere no it was uh san
salvador was it
or something like that some of those
little island chains down there but uh
yeah he never actually like landed on
the [ __ ] but it was a
it was a uh it was an astounding episode
it was they were making a mountain out
of a mole hill every [ __ ] minute
well it was specifically about the three
antichrists
yeah thing because i was like the thing
about nostradamus is he's just kind of
like
he was not a dummy and since he was like
making money from being a prophet and a
seer and everything he had like all the
[ __ ] tricks down man it's just like
make everything super super vague
don't do anything in any order don't put
anything in any order so people can just
like interpret it however i mean that's
what you have to do
match and pick that's what psychics do
called the same thing what he did was he
had these little like stanzas he called
them quatrains
yeah because he wanted to be fancy then
he arranged the quatrains in things that
he would call centuries
and the centuries were like chapters
but they weren't in any kind of order it
wasn't like century one
i think there might have been numbers to
them but he's not talking about one
century from now
or two centuries from now yeah they're
just kind of it's just it's a hodgepodge
it's like saying group
group one group two group three
so what that allowed you to do is uh
it allowed whoever bought the book or
whoever you know asked you a question
you could find something over here that
looks like it fits and then
20 pages deeper you can find another one
that sounds like it
hey that sounds like that that was just
going on over and each one's very vague
vague and very common [ __ ]
yeah but it sounds kind of impressive
and flowery
it's like it's like uh what do you call
it horoscopes
yeah basically well they've done it's a
very popular thing to do
in uh like critical thinking classes and
stuff where it's like they'll just be
like
hey we're gonna like get everybody tell
me what your um star sign is and we're
gonna print out everyone's horoscopes
and they'll give it to you and it's like
now you gotta rate how accurate it is
and of course everyone's like oh it's
super accurate they're like guess what
we gave you all the same one
yeah and what's dumbasses
nothing nothing that's funny about
nostradamus stuff is that it's
really only like a few handfuls of
quatrains
they get repeated they're getting
repeated that people really focus in on
because by accident just because he's
made so many of them
those have kind of landed closest to
things that have
sound like they may have happened in
history the rest of them is [ __ ]
gibberish or
not really gibberish they're so vague
and they're so
uninteresting that nobody ever looks at
those yeah
they're like you know they're they're
kind of silly
you know well it's just kind of like
he's doing he's covering all his bases
yeah
i mean if you write enough and honestly
probably
what he did was i mean you know we've
talked about this before i mean history
is
cyclical yeah so if you write about [ __ ]
that's going on right now like hey this
war over here or whatever
it's like you know it probably in the
future something very like that will
happen again
so i just i just feel like that's a
really like easy way to
make you make yourself look like a
[ __ ] prophet because
yeah and the more the more qua trades
you write the
the wider net you're cast yeah for just
in case things in the futures kind of
end up kind of sounding like that
and eventually he did get some hits
it's not true though they're not talking
about hitler they're not talking about
napoleon
another thing is is that how they
characterized napoleon a lot
not really accurate you know yeah the
the royalty didn't like him
but a lot of the common people liked him
because he was anti-royalist he was
trying to start
basically trying to start an eu that's
what he was trying to do
trying to unite the kingdoms of europe
into these into nations and
make a big republic he was an egomaniac
sure but they all were back then i mean
you know i would imagine his ego was
probably no bigger than an average king
he ended up making and then once he kind
of took over a big
part of the land you know he's like i'm
emperor i'm the king of kings
yeah but you know kneel down and worship
me [ __ ]
yeah i don't think he asked anybody to
worship
no i just not as a deity because he
it was a secular republic he was trying
to make
but um we're sitting there we're
watching this nostradamus
show and we're like reminiscing what it
was like to be a little kid
watching hbo and watching the man who
saw tomorrow yeah and [ __ ] with orson
welles with orson welles the man who
sold no wine before
right he could make that [ __ ] sound
spooky as
[ __ ] i saw that so many times when i was
a kid that
[ __ ] that program was written
masterfully yeah because it started
small and he would tell you a little
thing and they said oh and that should
happen
and then later on then they dug
nostradamus up and around his neck
was a plate with that date yeah and they
drank out of his skull it was like a
magic trick
yeah so then they're [ __ ] talking
about
all these past things that supposedly
came true and each time in between
[ __ ] every time you give up
he would tell you some [ __ ] came true in
history they
cut to orson well his fat orson is
sitting behind a desk and his fat ass
and [ __ ] turn sideways and look at
you like oh
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and he's like and then
this is not enough
the more he has seen in the future
like that you know and you're just like
you're you're like [ __ ] at
seven or twelve and you're going wait a
minute oh man he's got a good [ __ ]
track record
and he's talking about the terrible
things that will come to the future
yeah because you remember when the
antichrist remember when the world ended
in 1999
yeah yeah i remember that 1999 seventh
month arrived
the great king of terror you know
bringing fire down on the new city
which i think they kind of chopped a
couple of uh
of of of of what he called them
quatrains together to
get to make it that exact reading then
they showed the [ __ ]
twin towers in a [ __ ] ball of [ __ ]
fire a missile shot from [ __ ] iran
remember that
yeah and blew this [ __ ] up in a nuclear
and what was funny is like when 9 11 was
happening i thought back to that [ __ ]
yeah
and that's it and i was like [ __ ]
i was like it's 2001 that's close to
1999 and now there's those
close enough nostradamus knows
everything got those same goddamn
buildings [ __ ] falling down but then
you go to the qua trains and there's
doesn't mention anything about
buildings or anything just says a new
city well all cities are new
if you you know when you really at some
point at some point they're all new yeah
so that could be anything exactly and
well that's kind of the [ __ ] about i
mean we did a whole show about
nostradamus right where i was just kind
of like
psychics know this trick this is why you
keep [ __ ] vague because
people will supply their own meaning
yeah as long as you keep it you know
kind of
nebulous enough yeah that is new york
new york new york
you know so it's a new city yeah but you
know what i mean but the whole idea of
having the twin towers there
atomic missile the [ __ ] icbm coming
down
that was orson welles and his bunch that
came up with that [ __ ] they didn't have
anything to do with those pajamas no
coming up with that imagery i mean i did
love that
i saw that so many times yeah as a kid
like when you're a kid
you kind of be like what sounds legit i
wonder
i wonder how that's aged you could
probably watch that for free on youtube
i imagine someone's
maybe you saw tomorrow yeah yeah there
was another one that [ __ ]
came out before that that i saw on vhs
it scared
scared me but not as bad that was a kid
didn't scare me as bad as [ __ ] man
it's all tomorrow that was called
[ __ ] what was the name of that one what
was it about
the late great planet oh earth
great planet earth that's uh what's that
do you dream how lindsay yeah
it's like a christian end times
christian that's what it's called yeah
and it was cheesy
well it was cheesy but you know when
you're a kid and you have a religious
background you're going oh yeah oh yeah
moses knew all that [ __ ] oh yeah there's
[ __ ]
jesus coming back oh yeah [ __ ] it was
yeah [ __ ] plagues of frogs just
whatever you know what i mean just
mind-blowing [ __ ] the late great planet
earth and just there's something about
the way it was
presented i haven't seen that [ __ ] since
i was a little kid it's probably not
scary at all
no probably why not i mean it was just
kind of like that whole
um you know christian eschatology
whatever like the end of the world
[ __ ] yeah which a lot of them still do
that like some of you like cults and
everything
i don't remember i remember hearing
about the late great planet earth but i
don't remember if i ever actually sat
down and watched the whole thing
but the nostradamus because i wasn't you
know i wasn't raised religious and i
wasn't really all that interested in it
um but i did see the nostradamus one
with orson welles and yeah and somebody
said right after orson welles indulged
in some palmas online
yeah if you guys have seen like the um
there's video
of the outside of the from those
commercials yeah
and he's just like so is he [ __ ]
hammered he's [ __ ] happy
he's hammering he's [ __ ] hammered oh
they said that oh my god
they said that in that era it costs a
lot of money to hire horus and wells
yeah okay uh they paid him in booth
a lot of money and he didn't give a [ __ ]
how much of your film he burned up
and he was [ __ ] hammered they said he
would be hammered through
most of the little jobs he would do i
mean he wouldn't do it if he couldn't be
hammered
yeah that was one he weighed [ __ ] 250
300 pounds
i mean those outtakes are so so funny
yeah
she's like staring off at his face and
they're like uh hello yeah and like you
can see like the other two people in
there just like looking at each other
and like looking and going oh crap man
we gotta like do this again
yeah it's just it's very very funny and
what i remember about
[ __ ] that that was that was [ __ ] from
when i was a kid the palmer side wine
that was a california wine i believe
yeah and it was like it was up there
with like
[ __ ] it was just i guess
i don't want to say poor people wine it
was just cheap wine
but they wanted to like give one of them
like it was just like
you know it's a budget wine but they
want to make it seem like fancy
made that [ __ ] look fancy as [ __ ] yeah
you probably only sold it for about six
bucks a bottle five bucks a bottle
you know yeah which that was that was
okay back then you know just for
regular wine that you bought at the damn
grocery grocery store
yeah sure but yeah yeah those outtakes
are funny so you should like definitely
go look i don't remember where i saw him
i think it was on youtube
somebody put him up on there i think but
didn't dan bell put him up
edited into one of his videos or
something i think maybe he did it's just
funny how he or something like that he
could just [ __ ] orson welles could
just [ __ ] be have so much gravitas he
could just make something cheap sound
important and he just looked at you like
he's telling you i'm telling you the
truth
it's just like okay well some people
just have that gift
yeah that it's like no matter they can
just say the craziest [ __ ] imaginable
and it may be like
okay no way really yeah okay i buy it it
worked back then it probably wouldn't
work now
yeah but uh yeah
yeah somebody mentioned uh the movie a
hole in the ground i really like that
too and actually that was on my
initial list but i had to like winnow it
down like i said so it's so it was in
there like in my top 40 or 50 or
whatever i had somebody was talking
about the damn alien autopsy video that
was going around that was much later did
the alien autopsy that was 90s that was
90s i was out of the army by that time
and what was funny is that it must have
been around 95 96
i think when that came out yeah i feel
like it was somewhere around there maybe
97.
trying to place it in time
i kind of thought there was something to
it you know what i mean they were they
were [ __ ]
talking about hey man they got a they
think that they got alien autopsy videos
and um they wouldn't show it on tv
they would just have it on the news you
know what i mean and it was like a lot
of scuttlebutt about it
my local video store bought that [ __ ]
they had like three of them
and they were like checked out for like
two days straight well yeah finally i
went down there and [ __ ] got my hands
on one and watched it
and i was impressed man [ __ ] i was
like dude man that's an alien and i
watched it over and over again and it
slowly started to break down like
that's not that alien was from a costume
shop too i mean like from
well you wouldn't know back then you
didn't have internet you couldn't check
anything yeah that's true
i'm just looking at it and i'm going wow
man that's that's what they're talking
about huh that's
great but then yeah yeah but i started
noticing that there's
there was stuff about the video that
didn't really jive
like uh well they weren't really doing
the they're doing an autopsy they just
cut it open and took some stuff out of
it yeah they're like oh let's just slap
that over there in that [ __ ] box like
they weren't measuring it or anything
right and i'm going like this doesn't
look too scientific no
they're like they're just in like a
[ __ ] they're not even in a surgical
room
yeah they're just like in the doctor's
office and if you if you really had
i don't know i feel like you would film
it better like you would have close-ups
on each of your
organs you would do all that kind of
stuff this is for posterity yeah and
then i'm going like
why is it just those people in there in
that little bitty room doing it why
aren't why isn't there like about 30 or
40 [ __ ] people
yeah looking like observing sure yeah
and and like military people and [ __ ]
government people and a bunch of [ __ ]
high-tech
doctors and then why are they holding
the camera by hand why isn't it on a
tripod yeah
so i started thinking [ __ ] like that
yeah so the lighting isn't really good
in here you've got an extra terrestrial
and you're
you got kind of shitty lighting yeah you
know what i mean i'm just going
and you're doing it wrong and it's like
one dude and a nurse yeah i'm like
i'm going like you would think it'd be a
whole teams of dudes
and unless they're taking [ __ ] up they'd
be [ __ ] showing you [ __ ]
and like where's the x-ray of this thing
they had x-rays yeah
you know so i wanted to fall apart
yeah the more i watched it the more you
think about it i thought about it
i'm going like that that's not real i
wanted it to be real
i said well maybe it was some kind of
hasty thing you know but then i'm going
no there would be no hasty thing if they
found a [ __ ]
no of course extraterrestrial i mean
that would be like a huge use
yeah it all started descending on it and
you'd have
you'd have recognizable [ __ ] geniuses
and experts in there
at that time back in the 50s yeah i mean
[ __ ] you might have had [ __ ] albert
einstein up in that [ __ ]
give me a crack at that alien yeah look
at it oh yes
because they just would have called the
smartest man they knew back they had
back in the day you know
look at that you know oh yes oh my god i
just thought of a new screenplay
uh albert einstein versus the alien he's
going to do that
an autopsy i watch that albert einstein
alien autopsy
every time somebody cuts something out
of there albert's got an explanation
what about it what about it albert oh
yes i see
oh my god why would you write the script
yeah i totally would i mean i don't know
i feel like no one's done that yet well
you know maybe they have they've made
movies about it they're all kind of
crazy [ __ ] yeah it could be a whole
series yeah
um yeah so i i just feel like well a lot
of the
and the the nostradamus effect history
channel thing too
a lot of these if you're not if you're
just watching it and you're not really
paying attention or you don't have your
like critical thinking skills engaged
like i can under i can totally
understand like i can totally understand
how
like your dad would have watched the
mermaid [ __ ] and
thought that mermaids were real i mean
obviously i know mermaids are not real
so i'm just like watching it
but even if i hadn't even know if i was
open to the possibility that mermaids
were real which they're not
i think like five minutes less than five
minutes into that [ __ ]
when they were talking to the doctor i
was like that's an actor yeah because
they were too young or too pretty
yeah i was like that's totally not a
real just stop it
i mean at least get better looking like
get more realistic looking people if you
really want it to be like a mockumentary
there couldn't be mermaids just
biologically it couldn't happen
no um and if there were mermaids they'd
swim up on the beach and
lay down next to people sunbathing and
[ __ ] just like seals do
yeah they'd be everywhere it's just like
uh there can't be a loch ness monster
there has to be a breeding population if
there's a breeding population they'd be
laying up on the bank
a lot yeah just see them [ __ ] yeah
you would see them all the time all the
time [ __ ] splashing around laying
there isn't that [ __ ] locked now is
he laying across the road or whatever
little babies would be jumping around on
the [ __ ] bank and jumping back in
if there's a it would be a whole
ecosystem if something that big
it doesn't things that big don't hide
just ask elephants they don't hide
they're just like [ __ ] you out of the
way they're big i'm a big [ __ ]
elephant [ __ ]
i just go wherever the hell i want to
exactly tell me no i'm just going to
step right on you and then you have
animals that
so you have animals that big
and you have to have a breeding
population of them which might be what
50 or 60 of them i mean at least you
would think
and then you go down to loch ness and
you look at the bottom and then you look
at the water itself and there's no
food in it so what are they eating
that's what i mean they stay vegetarian
they would have to eat like a lot of
calories
yeah and there's not enough to eat in
there no there's
very little vegetation on on the floor
of it
i don't even think there are that many
fish before i remember correctly it's
not like
that place is not really known for its
fishing you can fish there but i don't
think you know
you're not going to support a breeding
population of
people like [ __ ] dinosaurs big
[ __ ] dinosaur things
and they're not going to be hiding from
you yeah because why would they
no oh [ __ ] here's the people yeah
[Laughter]
just we got alligators here they don't
[ __ ] hide and they're nowhere near
that big well i hope not
fight someone that big [ __ ]
got videos here in florida [ __ ] 12
foot alligator just walking across a
damn street
stopping traffic just [ __ ] proud yeah
[ __ ] just walking like well i'm going
over here man what are you gonna do
wait yeah getting going in people's
[ __ ] backyards
taking a dip in the pool in a swimming
pool chilling out for a while going yeah
i like this water
not big enough though i'm getting onto
the next one and they get up and go
they're [ __ ] a trip man it's a
[ __ ] dinosaur
it is and they don't hide not at all
and go up there and [ __ ] with that
alligator they'll charge you they'll run
right up on you
yeah remember that video of that [ __ ]
giant one in florida that was walking
across the golf course
yeah holy crap was huge that was a
[ __ ] bigger than a horse lower
that was one of the biggest [ __ ]
alligators i ever saw i thought at first
time i saw it i thought it was fake but
then i was like no i guess it's not
it wasn't fake because they had it from
like several different angles because a
lot of people
if some ang if some old-timey british
knights
saw that thing they'd say that was a
[ __ ] dragon yeah
they'd go that's a dragon yeah and they
wouldn't really be all that wrong would
they
um so before we wrap up i just wanted to
recommend if you didn't know netflix
just added a four-part
docu-series called crime scene
the vanishing at the cecil hotel and
it's essentially about the elisa lamb
case um although it goes a little bit
into like some other [ __ ] that happened
at the cecil hotel as well
one thing that i thought was really
interesting that they went into and i
don't know if we really wanted this
because we did a show
about elisa lamb like a while back but i
like that they went into
the whole web sleuth community and how
them getting interested in the case
because of the very famous elevator
video
was kind of like a double-edged sword in
the sense that everybody thought
because remember they talked about to
that one guy that black metal
musician yeah they went after mexican
morbid and um
just because i mean on the flimsiest of
[ __ ] evidence
like oh he was staying at the hotel
which he wasn't they found out he was
staying at the hotel but a year before
yeah you know what i mean um and he
looked like a death metal guy
he really was yeah yeah and he made
videos about like you know murdering
something like death metal people do
um so you know like every other that's
all playing it as far as
music videos yeah he seemed like a
lovely guy
um and uh basically the web sleuth
community
ruined the dude's life i mean because
they
somehow decided that he was the one that
had killed her it wasn't what didn't
start with them
it was it was a taiwanese news agency
yeah that's right saw pictures of him
and was like oh he must be a murderer
and the taiwanese little and it was like
a cheap news agency was like a web news
they said this is the suspect in the
case
yeah they basically just said that he
was which he wasn't
yeah and he was they weren't telling the
western audiences that they were telling
the taiwanese audience that
yeah and the webster's found this
taiwanese
report and saw this dude's face
and and evidently they go oh well that's
him
even in taiwan they know yeah and they
were making that [ __ ] up
there's yellow journalism [ __ ] the
whole planet's filipino rife with it
in case you haven't noticed but yeah the
poor guy i mean he just got [ __ ]
death threats all the time he couldn't
go anywhere
because everybody ruined his [ __ ]
life it did and it's really sad they
interview him
some like on this one and um but it's
interesting too because they talk about
like some true crime you youtubers that
i watch like um
that lord and guy from brain scratch and
stephanie harlow and stuff
and they're kind of like talking about
how everybody got so
into this case and it's like you know
it's a murderer who did it and all this
other kind of stuff
and then they just got totally carried
away and they actually do kind of admit
that like after because they're like
once the autopsy report came out and
they said no it was probably an accident
because
you know there was all this other stuff
that came out um and then they're like
no that can't be right it has to be like
this big conspiracy and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so they just like went
wildly off the rails
um and if it's interesting because if
you watch the documentary
i just kind of feel like i don't
remember what we said about it on our
show because i said well i guess there's
a bare possibility that it might be a
murder but now that i don't think that
it is a murder i think
i think that she just went off her meds
i think we she went off for meds and had
a psychotic episode sadly and i think
she just climbed in there
herself so you know for some weird
reason she was tripping she went there
to go find baby sass
yeah yeah baby sauce was not in there
baby says yeah she's gonna hang out with
baby sass
cheryl mackwood says did you guys see
don't [ __ ] with cats on netflix yes you
did uh
and yeah we reviewed that too that was
like really really upsetting for me to
watch that was good that was about luca
manana but that like i said i i don't
i don't have anything against like the
web sleuth community like on reddit or
whatever because
i think in a lot of cases they have
actually helped to solve some crimes
you know because you're crowdsourcing it
um and sometimes especially if it's cold
cases
and like the cops aren't really working
on it anymore because they don't have
any leads
it's like sometimes that can be really
helpful but they kind of talked about it
a little bit on this documentary too
it's like but
sometimes it can really [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] because sometimes people come up
with these [ __ ] conspiracy theories
and they don't have all the information
that the cops have
so they're just kind of like weaving
things out of the limited information
that they have
and then they're calling the cops and
being like well it must be this guy or
why
did you check this out did you do that
is it bothering the cops and it's
bothering the cops and it's like you
know they're they're having to like
spend all this time
like going into [ __ ] that they can't
release all the information they have
right to the public
so so yeah so they're operating the
public is operating on limited
information
which they were in the alisa lam case
too there was some stuff that they
couldn't let out because they did
actually when they first started they
said well it's it's a suspicious death
so we're going to investigate it as if
it was a homicide until we can decide
otherwise
so they were actually investigating it
as though it wasn't they knew that she
was met
she they knew that she was uh had mental
problems and they knew that there had
been some incidents she'd been doing
a day or two prior yeah
which i don't know if they released to
the public at the time they did
she's going down to the lobby and
[ __ ] goes yeah i'm crazy but
la is crazy too and she'd be doing robot
movements and stuff
well and they kicked her out of it she
went to a tv taping and they kicked her
out of the picture
taping and her roommates said she was
acting weird they had to change it they
had to put her in another round
because they wouldn't she would lock
them out and not let them in without a
password just [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] like
that
yeah so she was acting real she was like
for a day or two they looked into her
medicine bottles and there was too much
medicine in there for the time of
the [ __ ] month so she wasn't taking
her medicine yeah and um
she started hallucinating and her they
talked to her sister and this again i
think this is uh
also information that they didn't
release to the public until recently
but they interviewed her sister and her
sister said yeah when she's not on her
meds or she's not taking them regularly
she
has psychotic episodes very much like
what you saw in the elevator video
where she absolutely would think people
were after her she would hide from
people
um she was seeing people she was having
like hallucinations
um i mean when they showed the sister
the elevator video i mean they basically
she said yes that's
that's what she does when she's like off
her meds she acts like that
yeah and she just went up on the roof
you could get on the roof pretty easily
there's two different ways to do it
she got up on top of that damn tank and
opened it up and jumped in there
couldn't get out so she treaded water
took her clothes off to lighten the load
she eventually drowned in there i don't
know how strong of a swimmer she was
yeah and uh they found her in there was
a food about a week later
19 days 19 like two two days yeah
they're not entirely sure
yeah well because she was pretty um you
know she was thinking of water
they weren't entirely sure how long
she'd been in there but they just
assumed
that she probably went up there like not
too long after the elevator thing
because the clothes that they found in
there were the same ones that she had on
you know what i mean so they just
assumed that it was probably 19 days she
was in there
and yeah they were drinking the water
and they said that they said that you
know that the
lid to the damn tank had been closed
behind her after she jumped in that was
a lie
the uh the uh the workman guy
said that later on he is you know he
said in spanish
he goes no when i found her the lid was
open he says yeah saw the lid was open i
looked in there and saw her
yeah it's a hatch it doesn't even have
it doesn't even have a hinge no
you just pull it off and put it aside
it's like a lid and we'll see what ended
up happening was there was a very famous
clip of like a cop
and he's saying from my understanding
when we got there the lid was closed
which would lead you to believe that
someone had murdered her because she
wouldn't be able to close it
after her like after she got in there
but it wasn't true like they interviewed
the employee that found her and he was
like no when i got up there the hatch
was off that's why i thought it was
weird and that's why i looked in there
yeah you know what i mean yeah what was
funny is that if the if the tank was
full uh you know the tank was constantly
trying to fill itself as people were
using the water
she could have reached up and grabbed
the lid and gotten out of there
if she was in the right mind probably
because it continued to try to fill
itself up
there's no there's no proof that she
couldn't
reach that maybe she couldn't see it
yeah maybe
or she's just hallucinating too bad yeah
she may have not
have survived very long in that tank
swimming maybe she might have been a
real weak swimmer
it didn't really say yeah well they
didn't really know
she was in a conditions in a psychotic
condition and just was a weak swimmer
because of her condition you know i'm
not like
yeah because she you know yeah because
she was moving
very strange moving weird and yeah
and she might have just thought that
well you know i mean with baby sass and
i'm gonna take a big breath of this what
take a big
breath of this water yeah see if i can
breathe water
you know that's that's how crazy she was
and it's
yeah like i said it's really sad if you
take a big old breath of water it kills
you pretty much instantly
i mean it you you instantly lose
consciousness yeah
you know some people think that you know
you you linger on
no i think from everything i've heard is
those lungs are fully
filled you somehow just shut down
you know like a second or two yeah yeah
it's supposed to be kind of a peaceful
death dream yeah i'm not going to like
uh
you know check that out or anything i'm
just saying i've heard that i don't know
if it's true
i don't it's like nobody's come back
from the dead to like you know confirm
that
you don't doesn't kill you instantly you
lose consciousness in instantly if you
[ __ ] pull
a big breath in i mean i was hearing
some of those [ __ ] divers you know
[ __ ]
combat divers saying that you know they
would kind of try to drown each other as
tests
as part of [ __ ] can you get your damn
[ __ ]
um mask back on or your breather going
your rebreather going again that kind of
[ __ ]
because they're constantly stressing
each other out in those pools yeah
it's part of the their training and uh
they were saying that if you ever got in
a position you know where there was no
way to reach the surface
and your rebreather starts to
malfunction
or you know you're going to [ __ ]
slowly die you know from
from a loss of air because your
rebreather is [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and says you know you might
as well just take it off and just take a
deep breath
get it over with that way you're not
struggling yeah yeah
yeah cheryl says i think she died of
hypothermia that was enough
yeah that was another because i don't
they didn't find they talked to the um
the uh forensic pathologist and he said
well
it's like normally in a drowning case
you would see this kind of like foam
inside her lungs
like she didn't have that um but that
doesn't necessarily mean that she didn't
drown
so she may very well may have drowned or
she may have died of hypothermia because
those were kind of like the two because
there were no other marks like on her
body or anything anywhere
and you know no marks of violence or
anything so they couldn't really
determine
like what exactly that she died of so it
could have been drowning or could have
been hypothermia
yeah um might have been just a mixture
of everything though she might have
stripped her clothes off
because maybe she was a weak swimmer to
lighten the load yeah it could be
several things she takes her clothes off
to lighten the load but the water was
cold so then she starts losing body heat
and then hypothermia sets in and she
can't swim
because she's just too stiff from the
[ __ ] hypothermia
yeah yeah you get cold you don't you
kind of lose your limber
you know your muscles start tense it up
yeah like i said it's just
it's just a really sad yeah case a
person a person in in
sound mind could have gotten back out of
there probably yeah
i mean depending on what the level of
the water in the tank happened to be at
the time because if it was like way down
there no you couldn't get back up but if
it was like
it wasn't what they said it never really
got that low
yeah and they said that even if it got
kind of low you could still reach it
yeah there was no constantly refilling
itself yeah
so it you know and it evidently never
really got all that low you know
yeah the difference of only a few feet
yeah yeah
and if you're a weak swimmer maybe you
can't do a burst up and [ __ ] grab it
yeah and you might have to wait for a
few minutes for it to go back up you
can't swim well enough to wait for those
few minutes
maybe she didn't [ __ ] really want to
get out maybe she was hiding from
somebody
yeah because you know people were after
her and the hypothermia
yeah took her clothes off so she could
swim easier and then the hypothermia set
in
and she's still hiding from baby sass
something like that
yeah yeah cheryl said she was from
vancouver canada where i live
it was big news here yeah it was like a
[ __ ] massive case and but i think
mostly because of that [ __ ] elevator
video because that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
pretty weird
um all right so we finally covered
everything i wanted to cover
yeah yeah okay we had to do an extra day
[Laughter]
to do it but there's a lot of material
and you know the way the computer was
acting and then [ __ ] way we were
acting from all that alcohol and [ __ ]
it's going to take too long
but no we made it up to the audience and
we might have to we might do something
like this again anyway there's no reason
why we can't stream
whatever whenever yeah we're going to
have to change
saturday anyway eventually yeah because
eventually we're going to want to start
going back out on saturdays so we might
change the main show to friday
right um but it might be like a few
weeks before we do that and we'll like
announce before we do it
but yeah because we kind of miss going
out on saturdays yeah i miss going out
period
yeah you know [ __ ] the [ __ ]
knights
the nightclub scene is weak
they don't come back though yeah
eventually we hope
yeah it'll be it'll be all right
everything will be all right
all right [ __ ] trying to
apocalypse us nobody's trying to
apocalypse you
everything's going to be all right don't
worry she's very
optimistic she's an optimistic woman
she's a good person so she thinks
nobody's trying to hurt her
me i'm not that good and i think people
are trying to hurt me no one's trying to
hurt you it goes all the way back to the
free state of jones
you think everyone's just getting it it
is in our [ __ ] dna
i'm not an optimist i'm a realist i just
i know that most people are just
indifferent to me
you know what i mean it's it's not so
much that it's all kumbaya it's like no
one gives a [ __ ] about me so
well that's the same why would they why
would they [ __ ] with me that's the same
as coming you know what i mean they're
gonna start doing [ __ ]
that will affect me because they don't
know about me
you don't understand the [ __ ] you
don't understand how it [ __ ] works
all right
i learned it in the army too [ __ ] rolls
downhill they do [ __ ] it rolls downhill
onto you well yeah i don't trust them
don't trust them i don't like them i
don't care who they are i know you don't
okay all right not in my nature i know
it isn't
okay all right you ready to sign off i'm
ready let's go i'm getting like kind of
sleepy i mean it's probably only like
quarter to eight but you know
we're like ragged out from last night
yeah didn't get great sleep really
yeah i mean i i woke up pretty early
because pookie was like you know she
likes to come out she's like i'm gonna
sleep by mommy
you know but yeah so
uh we'll be back we're probably not
going to stream tomorrow but um because
we wouldn't usually
we just did this one extra so we'll be
back on saturday
at 5 00 p.m eastern time with our
uh regular episode which like i said is
going to be about the source family
cult and maybe another call i don't know
we'll we'll see
it'll be fun so it's in another cult
show you guys seem to like those
and uh this is like a hippie cult so
we're gonna like make fun of hippies
just kidding all right so uh we will see
you guys on saturday and thanks for
dropping by this little extra show
uh we'll see you later bye